production sound mixer is is charged
with the responsibility of capturing the
original performances of all the the
talent the artists on the set and in
collaboration with the director and his
intention and how it's seen and a show
should come to pass so how an audience
experiences that sonically is is the
main responsibility we deal with the the
artists in close quarters intimately day
to day throughout the production and our
charge is to capture those performances
in a way that they survive to be in the
end the end film a lot of my job on
location involves problem solving
because the parameters of the shooting
are set up by the camera people and then
I have to figure a way to get it good
recording working within those
strictures so it's it's a it sounds
straightforward but in fact there's a
lot of ways to imagine a scene working
sound wise and some directors are very
sound savvy and very aware of it and
have strong notions of what they would
like I tribute a a relationship to the
drummer in the band because I think what
we do as essentially like sidemen
musicians each with an intense passion
for a particular instrument which comes
into full bloom as we play with other
musicians in the orchestra in the
drummer we are kind of invisible until
we stop so without the beat there's
there's no music and and without the
sound the film becomes mute generally
speaking on a film set there's 150
people and they're all working pretty
much with the interest of what the
things look like whatever their function
is it's around trying to make the
picture at some level except for the two
or three of us who are doing the sound
so everyone is thinking about what it
looks like and there's only a couple few
servlets eyes
in lame is obviously this was a this was
a musical so most of the sound had sort
of musical content be there's bit the
live singing from from onset or or
everything else that went with it it's
basically just a question of getting all
that sound together and getting all
ready to be mixed that's that's the
process
Samri recording is where we're blending
the soundtrack of the movie together so
we come on when the film has been shot
the films been edited and the last part
is to put the soundtrack together so I'm
usually working with all the production
tracks that are recorded on the set
along with any loop tracks that are done
to replace sounds that the actors need
to be replaced it's sometimes there's a
if you're doing a period film and then
aircraft goes by obviously they have to
re-record their dialogue things like
that and then performance take sometimes
that re done then I take all of those
elements and adjust them take out some
noise of ambient noise and clean up a
lot of the dialogue make it so you can
actually hear it so you're not chasing
your remote at home all the time
hopefully and then we work with the
orchestra or the band that's been
recorded for the music and the songs
that are put into the film and then all
the sound effects you know the footsteps
are split from all the other elements
and then all the spot effects the
atmospheric elements that's a lot more
of the nitty gritty and then during the
final mix when the director on a more of
the kind of creative other departments
come in then we're making slightly
broader decisions about the overall
sound for the movie and introducing the
music and I guess that's where the fun
starts
the salient thing about what we do is
it's not a technical job it's
must be watching the screen you must be
watching the movie and responding to the
film and I think for anybody who wants
to mix sound you know in a film you have
to remain audience you have to always be
thinking of yourself as an audience
member and how other people view the
film and and mix it accordingly there's
a grand evolution that's happened in
terms of our tools both for camera and
sound over the last you know few decades
and that's very important and you need
to know them with with great intensity
but don't let them drive what you're
doing only inform what you're doing you
need to be driven more by the filmmaking
you know where are we going what is this
actor like what is the character that
the actors creating like and how does
this sound that you create support that
there's a great phrase phrase that says
music can't save about film but it can
absolutely lift a great one to another
dimension of wonder I think I think the
craft of music is a very very delicate
craft particularly nowadays I think
music can get in the way and hinder as
much as it could help but I think it's
it needs to be taken very very very
delicately and it needs to be carefully
understood my advice to people generally
when they ask me my opinion is to try
and find a young upcoming filmmaker
that's really got an interesting project
you're gonna have to get in there you're
gonna have to work for nothing you're
gonna have to throw yourself in but
you're going to potentially learn
together in a sense and grow and if that
director or writer happens to hit on
something that takes off you know with a
bit of luck you go along for the ride
learning some type of music in some way
even if you don't play you know if you
just really listen and use your musical
background I mean that'll help you quite
a bit I deal with composers I deal with
music editors and you know I go to the
scoring stage when they're recording you
know and I understand the language that
helps me a quite a bit when we get into
mixing with the composer right next to
me saying I want this I want that I want
little more than that I want to and he's
using musical terms I understand what
he's talking about I strongly urge that
you become a knowledgeable as a
filmmaker become literate as a filmmaker
go listen to movies and don't have some
preset notion that it's got to be
natural you know I've done in a movie
with Robert Altman who hated naturalism
is in the sound because it was
informational about the content and you
can't have some negative feeling about
that you have to embrace that and fall
in love with that there are many great
films that had all post sync sound I've
come from Eastern Europe and Italy in
other places are they lesser films
because they were not you know done
organically or naturally no they're
there their lessons on staying involved
with the characters staying involved
with the storylines staying involved
with the storytelling and as long as you
can do that and and support your
characters existence inside the illusion
of the film the rest of what you do will
fall into place